MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
MALE SPEAKER 1: GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
IKAI LAN: Good Afternoon,
New York City.
Good morning, if you're
somewhere else.
Late night, if you're
really far away.
Welcome to Apps Script
Office Hours.
My name is Ikai Lan.
JAN KLEINERT: I'm
Jan Kleinert.
IKAI LAN: And today, we have
a good show for you.
Well, it's pretty
straightforward.
There's nothing special
going on today.
But I do want announce events
that are coming up.
Next week we've got our
Austin Hackathon.
So if you're not yet signed up
and you're in the Austin area,
go on Google and search for Apps
Script Hackathon Austin.
It's going to be one
first results.
We've still got spots.
We need you to sign up because
we're ordering food, and
there's going to be
fun activities.
So for those of you that are not
in Austin, we are planning
a West Coast hackathon.
That's coming sometime
in November.
We'll be posting as soon
as we have the details.
So we're still working
on that.
But we hope to see you
at that event soon.
So yeah, that's what I have
for announcements.
JAN KLEINERT: Next, I think
we're going to go
over release notes.
We had a release
late last week.
And I'll just run through
what happened there.
And this was a release from
the evening of August 30.
So we added some new methods to
script properties and user
properties.
This is a feature request that
quite a few people had asked
for to be able to basically
delete properties and keys
from script properties
and user properties.
So we've added those methods.
We also added several other
methods to do things like
delete all properties, box set
properties, things like that.
So it's a lot more robust
of an API now.
IKAI LAN: This is a really big
deal because I know that
before, I was doing set
as null and undefined.
And that became really ugly
really fast, because you
couldn't delete the
properties.
And then, it caused a lot of
weird programming issues.
JAN KLEINERT: And you could
run up against your quotas
that way, too.
So it's a much more usable
interface now.
We also added a set
option method.
This is for the charts service
so that all of the different
charts builders can now set
advanced options for charts.
I think this came about because
somebody specifically
wanted to be able to set
multiple axes on the charts.
But now with this set option,
you can do a whole
lot more than that.
So there's links to the docs
from the release notes.
And then finally, we
fixed an issue.
This was just kind of a minor
issue with the script editor,
where if you had a really long
line somewhere in your script
and you'd scroll to the
right, the line
numbers would disappear.
So that's fixed now, too, which
makes it a little easier
to debug your code if
you have really long
lines in your script.
So those are our release
notes for the week.
IKAI LAN: I want to remind
people that a few weeks ago--
I think it was two weeks ago--
we rolled out a streamlined
interface for publishing to
the Chrome Web Store.
So we have a script
gallery now.
And it's where you'd want to
go if you wanted to publish
scripts for, say, spreadsheets
and what not.
But if you're starting to build
web apps in full apps
that have UI, you really should
be publishing in the
Chrome Web Store for much
more discoverability.
So I will be plugging this week
after week after week
until we start seeing
more applications.
And if you need any help, do
come to Stack Overflow and ask
us for help.
Or if you run into any problems,
come to the Issues
Tracker, and tell us where your
troubles are publishing,
and why you're not doing it, and
how we can help make this
easier for you.
JAN KLEINERT: Yeah, we are
starting to see some really
interesting things come into the
Chrome Web Store that were
built with App Scripts,
so it's very exciting.
OK, so that's it for
release notes.
Before we take live questions,
we have a lot of questions
here actually on the Moderator
page, which you can see linked
from the Google Developers Live
show listing for today.
So what do you say, Ikai?
Do you want to just take
these in order?
IKAI LAN: What order?
Whatever you want
to do these in.
JAN KLEINERT: All right, well,
let's just start at the top.
So I'll take this one first.
So the first question here--
"Is there a time frame for
adding the rest of the UI app
widgets to the GUI builder?"
I guess there was a comment from
when the GUI builder was
launching saying that we could
expect the rest of the widgets
to come shortly.
I'm not actually sure
about those plans.
I know we've added some of
the widgets over time.
But I don't have the specific
roadmap on when/if the rest of
the widgets will be added.
We can try to follow
up on that for you.
But off the top of my
head, I'm not sure.
IKAI LAN: OK.
Moving on to the
next question.
"I'm using content service to
create a web services that
uses the Gmail API
to access mail.
Can you explain the process
for how the user will
authorize the web
server script to
access their email account?
The web service has no direct
user interface."
So for everyone that's watching
right now, content
service is a way to
provide API-like
access to your scripts.
So let's say you want to put
out JSON, or XML, or some
other crazy format.
You would be using
content service
instead of HTML service.
Now, the problem with content
service is that because it's
not expected to use the inside
browser, you don't really have
a way to authorize access
to user data, such
as the Gmail service.
So I know that we're working
on a solution.
We have nothing to announce
at this point.
But we are working on a solution
so that you will be
able to build content
service applications
that users can authorize.
JAN KLEINERT: Right.
So the way that it works today,
it is possible if you
publish this.
So when you go in, and you've
built this, and you have to go
through the publish as a web app
workflow, if you publish
it to run as the developer, so
as you the script developer,
you can authorize it that
way and that will work.
But obviously, if you're using
something like Gmail, you
don't want to run against
your inbox.
You want it to run against
the user's inboxes.
And there's not a particularly
straightforward way of doing
that today.
So we were talking about
this morning.
And we have some plans
in place to
support that in the future.
But we can't get into
specifics yet.
But for sure it will be
in the documentation
once we have it available.
OK.
The next one here--
contextapp.getcontacts is
running slow for this
person here.
So we actually have an issue
in the tracker open.
I've linked to it in
the response here.
It's dealing with
the performance
issues for Get Contact.
We're looking into that.
But you can follow the
status of that issue
in the issue tracker.
We're aware that there are some
performance issues there.
IKAI LAN: OK, I noticed
that Jan set me up to
take this next one.
This one's actually
really confusing.
I don't want to read it out.
But I'll read it out.
It says "To build a UI, I use
both command lines in the
script and use GUI builder."
So it goes on a little bit.
And I'm not exactly sure
what this is asking.
Let me open it up to see if
there's any clarifications.
JAN KLEINERT: I don't
think so.
IKAI LAN: How to
study GUI Apps.
I'm not even sure if that's
what he's asking.
So why don't I move on to the
next one, which is "Is there a
way to password protect the
Apps Script attached to a
spreadsheet?"
The requirement is that when
we share the spreadsheet to
others in a company, we
don't want the Apps
Script visible to others.
Now, one way to do this is to
create code, and Jan answered
this, so I'm really just taking
credit for her work,
Create the code in a
separate project.
And what you can do is when you
publish a version, there
will be inside Project
Properties a--
it's a script key,
a project key.
Now, what you can do is, later
on in a different project, you
can import your important
functions.
You can say I want to import
a library and copy
the script key in.
So you copy and paste
that script key in.
And what you'll need to
do is you'll need
to provide a prefix.
So let's say I build a library
that has a function called Hi.
And I call the library
My Cool Library.
I would save this, publish a
version-- let's say version
one, version two, whatever--
and I would get a project key.
I would create a second project,
and I would import
it, and I'd namespace it.
So in my code, I would
write something like
MyCoolLibrary.hi.
Everything would be namespaced
and prefixed.
So in this case, you wouldn't
have to share the code, and
this would work.
JAN KLEINERT: Right.
So the spreadsheet of the
project that you want to
import the library into which
you want to put the library
will have to have at least view
access to that library.
But the users of the spreadsheet
aren't going to
have that library available
to them.
So you can use it within the
spreadsheet script, but it's
not visible to the users when
they go and look at the script
of the spreadsheet itself.
So that's a good way
of doing this.
But specifically what you ask
for to be able to password
protect the scripts, we
don't have that today.
I think there is actually
something in the issue tracker
for basically being able to
lock down and not show the
source of scripts.
But that's an open
feature request.
It's something we
have available.
OK.
Next one here, and this
one I haven't actually
read through yet.
So we'll take a look
on the fly.
"I'm learning to display data--
table options, grid,
FlexTable, HTML5 and others.
One record per page with
Next and Back.
Any options?" OK, so this sounds
like a question about
some of the different ways to
display data, probably mostly
within UI App, it sounds
like, If we're
looking at grid and FlexTable.
It really is going to depend
on your use case, so,
specifically, what you're trying
to do and what features
you need to be supported
to deal with your data.
And so if you can provide us--
if you can post a response
here, we'll take a look later,
and see if we can give you
more guidance on that.
But without knowing what sort of
date is, how much you have,
how you want to interact with
it, it's a little tricky to
make an across-the-board
recommendation.
I would say if you're
bent on using UI
App, that's one thing.
But if you're willing to use
HTML5 service, then it's
pretty wide open.
And you can kind of build
whatever you want.
And there's a lot of premade
solutions out there that might
work for you that other people
have built that many of them
will be compatible with
HTML5 service.
So that might be the more
flexible way to go, even
though it's not going to be
necessarily as out of the box
as some of the UI app widgets.
There may be stuff in jQuery
UI, for example,
that would work well.
IKAI LAN: The jQuery UI
stuff is pretty basic.
So there's probably stuff built
on top of jQuery UI.
But we need to go look for
it and need to test
it for it to work.
JAN KLEINERT: Right.
IKAI LAN: One thing that's
really new about spreadsheets
is that they are a built-in
UI for your application.
So depending on what it is
you're trying to do, sometimes
I find that if I'm replicating
too much spreadsheet
functionality, one thing that I
might do is I might just use
spreadsheet's input and build
a custom menu instead.
So again, it really depends
on what it is
you're trying to do.
But I feel like you have
a lot of options.
Moving on to the next one. "I
have a custom function in my
Apps Script.
How can I access it whenever I
open a new spreadsheet without
publishing it in the gallery?"
Well, one thing that you could
do is you could create a
template that has the
spreadsheet, and every time you
create a new spreadsheet,
you could clone the spreadsheet,
and you'll pick
up the function.
Other than that, you have the
script library option, which
is a little bit clunky.
I just feel like you want
global access to this.
Anything else comes to mind?
JAN KLEINERT: No.
This is something that we've
heard requested before,
particularly within an
organization that has a Google
Apps account to be able to have
an admin install scripts
across an account.
It's not something
we support today.
But I do believe there's
something in the issue tracker
or feature requests for that.
But what you mentioned with the
templates is a really good
option, too.
OK, so the next one here: "When
we publish a spreadsheet
as a web app, how can we make a
particular cell or multiple
cells editable on the HTML
page?" So I think this one, if
I'm understanding correctly,
is not actually
an App Script question.
So Google Spreadsheets has an
option in the sharing settings
to publish a spreadsheet as
a web page, which makes it
publicly viewable.
And it's no longer really an
interactive spreadsheet.
It's kind of this
read-only view.
So I'm not especially familiar
with what you can and can't do
in that view of the
spreadsheet.
But I imagine that if you
go to the Help pages for
spreadsheets, if this is
possible, they'll explain how
to do it there.
OK I think that's
all we've got.
Let me just refresh here and
double check, and then if
there's nothing else new--
ah, here's one more.
IKAI LAN: This is not a
App Script question.
JAN KLEINERT: This
last one here?
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
JAN KLEINERT: I'm not sure which
Google App this person
is referring to.
If you mean can you build
something with Google Apps
Script and use it and display
it publicly, I believe so.
But if you're asking something
else, maybe clarify the
question so we can
take a look.
IKAI LAN: Right.
Also, if your question is more
around the terms of use for
Apps Script, then there's a link
to the developer terms
from our documentation page.
So you can read through there
and see if that covers your
question as well.
OK, do we have anybody live in
the Hangout that wants to ask
a question?
IKAI LAN: Hey, guys.
I see we have some regulars.
And we have a new person who
I haven't seen before.
So before we get started, I just
want to put this on your
radar, which is we're thinking
about people that--
we're thinking about doing some
live interviews of some
team members.
Now, I've asked Sohrab, who is
the product manager for Google
Apps Script.
And he said I don't know.
People have seen me too much.
They don't want to
see me anymore.
And I said that's not true.
We want to interview you.
We want to see what you're
about, who you are.
So I'm still going to
try to rope him in.
But if there's any one of the
team that you guys think might
be interesting, I think it'd
be interesting to have a
conversation with Nikhil, who's
a TL, or Mike, who is
the uber TL.
That's the way I've heard
him referred to.
Or just individual software
engineers on the team working
on different things.
Like Corey's given talks at
Google I/O. And he always has
a lot to say, actually.
It's more about narrowing
the scope of the
things for him to say.
So if you guys have anyone that
you would like to see
interviewed, do let us know.
Anyway, all right, live
audience have at it.
JAN KLEINERT: Any questions
from you guys today?
IKAI LAN: Anything you guys
want to talk about?
MALE SPEAKER 3: Hey, how
are you guys doing?
Can you hear me OK?
JAN KLEINERT: Yeah, we
can hear you great.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Cool.
Thanks.
I have one quick question.
I've got a--
I'm really excited.
I've got a web app that I'm
just having my graphic
designer pretty up the UI and
some icons and stuff for the
Chrome Web Store.
And I'm thinking I'll probably
publish it for
free at this point.
But I was thinking about
monetization options.
One option, sell it for $0.99
or something like that.
And then I was thinking, you
know I'd really like to be
able to do is link my AdSense
account to it.
Is there any talk or has there
been any discussion around
about having an AdSense
service?
I tried that through a couple
of things, and the AdSense
JavaScript got stripped out.
JAN KLEINERT: It did?
OK.
MALE SPEAKER 3: I didn't seem
to be able to publish it.
IKAI LAN: OK.
JAN KLEINERT: Is your app
using HTML service?
MALE SPEAKER 3: No.
UI App.
JAN KLEINERT: UI App.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER 3: I tried to
use the HTML within it.
What I'd like to be
able to do is--
I was thinking it
would be good.
It'll run in a browser.
It's not an extension.
It's a UI.
And it works with Google Docs.
So it's timely and cool.
But I was thinking that one way
to monetize it would be to
have a AdSense panel
within the UI app.
But I can't see any easy way
do that at this point.
Any thoughts?
Comments?
JAN KLEINERT: I think you're
right that it's probably not
possible within UI app.
And I haven't actually tried
it in HTML service.
It's possible that it
would work there.
I'll have to check.
There may be some tricky
things that we'd
have to sort out first.
But I think it's a very good
request that we can take back
to the team.
And--
MALE SPEAKER 3: Issue
tracker material?
--certainly with web
apps that's a--
I'm sorry?
What's that?
MALE SPEAKER 3: Issue
tracker material?
JAN KLEINERT: Absolutely.
For sure.
IKAI LAN: I do have a question
for you, though.
Now, you mentioned that you
might want to sell the app.
So Jan, do you have any updates
about Chrome Web Store
and being able to do that?
JAN KLEINERT: So we're still
working through some of the
details on that.
So technically, yes,
it's possible.
The challenge that we have
today is we don't have a
simple way for you to then--
so the Chrome Web Store has a
licensing API, where you can
know-- so it's possible to sell
an app today, say $0.99,
whatever you choose.
And people can purchase
the app.
But then what we don't have is
round trip with the licensing
server to be able to query
for this user--
from your app for this user have
they purchase the app?
So it's not the full round-trip
solution today.
So there's a gap there,
basically.
And we're aware of it.
And we're working on solving it
in the future so that you
can have the reassurance
basically that--
and check on it, and that's
especially important for
things like free trials or
recurring subscriptions and
things like that.
IKAI LAN: So have you
used AdSense before?
I'm asking because for
things that are more
application-like--
and Jan has this famous
presentation from when she was
on the Chrome team about the
difference between an
application and web page--
AdSense may not be your best
bet, only because, unless
you're getting a huge volume,
it might not be enough to
cover your costs, which is one
reason that selling the
application in the Chrome Web
Store when we get that out
might be a very good option.
JAN KLEINERT: It may also
depend on the amount of
contextual content that's
in your app as well.
So you probably know the answer
to that one better than
we can guess.
But it may also be the kind
of thing once we have the
solutions totally worked out
for both sides of them that
you do kind of like an A/B test
sort of thing and see
what works best for your
particular web app.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Mostly
it's going to be--
it's for promotion.
And it's really solving a
problem that I've seen people
ask fixed for Google Docs.
So I don't expect it to
have a long lifespan.
In fact, any day, I would
imagine the Google Docs team
will announce something that'll
do the same thing.
But until then--
and there is some context to
it that might make AdSense
particularly interesting to
certain types of vendors.
IKAI LAN: OK.
JAN KLEINERT: Interesting.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Anyway, I
was just wondering if--
it is an application, but
people come back to it
repeatedly.
And there is some context to
it that might make sense.
JAN KLEINERT: OK
MALE SPEAKER 3: Although
I'll throw that
in the issue tracker.
IKAI LAN: Great.
JAN KLEINERT: Any other
live questions?
IKAI LAN: That is something
that we're seeing a lot of
usage for App Script, which is
extending the functionality
apps and bridging a lot of
different applications.
This is one thing that Sohrab,
the PM, was talking to me
about, which is that we think
that we're going to see a lot
of very powerful applications
that extend Docs.
So when you say the Docs team
might go ahead build this,
there's also a very good chance
that they might not and
would decide that it's something
which makes a lot
more sense as a script or
an extension, because it
doesn't apply to--
it applies to a small
subset of uses.
So App Scripts are really good
for if you want to build
something specific to
a specific vertical.
JAN KLEINERT: And it's
relatively quick and easy to
build these things and tailor
them to exactly how you want
to work, which is nice, too,
because everybody has their
own preferences for how they
want some of these extensions
and things to work.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Well, when it's
done, you'll take a look
at it, and I think you'll
see what I mean.
It's probably something that I
would expect that the Docs
team will come out with.
IKAI LAN: OK.
JAN KLEINERT: OK.
Well, we're certainly interested
to check it out.
MALE SPEAKER 3: I'm hoping to
have it by next week in the
Chrome Web Store.
We'll see how fast
my designer goes.
JAN KLEINERT: OK.
Definitely let us know.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Cool.
Will do.
I think there looks
like there's some
stuff in the chat.
JAN KLEINERT: OK.
So we don't--
MALE SPEAKER 3: On
the Hangout.
JAN KLEINERT: --actually have
that visible at the moment.
We may be able to switch
over to that possibly
on the other screen.
IKAI LAN: We've got
Eric producing.
Eric is normally in this chat.
But he's back there.
He's making all of the--
MALE SPEAKER 3: Is that why the
screen's a little crooked?
IKAI LAN: Is it?
MALE SPEAKER 3: The camera's
a little crooked?
IKAI LAN: Oh, are we?
JAN KLEINERT: Maybe
we're crooked.
It's possible.
IKAI LAN: Maybe I'm-- maybe--
here, let me fix
myself right there.
This is a shared studio.
That's all I'm going to say.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Don't tell
him I said that.
JAN KLEINERT: Yeah,
unfortunately,
I think that is--
I can see the all caps comment
that says "Any news about
Google Glass?" No, we
don't have any news
about Google Glass.
I can't read it.
I'm sorry.
IKAI LAN: Let me do this.
Let me solve this.
JAN KLEINERT: We'll fix this
technical problem in the
future when--
MALE SPEAKER 3: It looks like,
actually now, I'm looking at a
question from--
a clarification on the one
from the modifier.
JAN KLEINERT: Oh, that's great.
OK.
IKAI LAN: OK, so there's
a lot of junk in here.
MALE SPEAKER 3: There is
some junk, too, yeah.
IKAI LAN: Let's see.
OK.
He's asking should he use
the GUI builder or
programmatically create
an application
using the program coding.
JAN KLEINERT: Oh, OK.
Whether to use UI app
programmatically to build it
versus GUI builder?
IKAI LAN: Right.
JAN KLEINERT: So that depends
on a couple things.
So GUI builder is going to
give you a subset of the
functionality of UI apps.
So if GUI builder can do
everything that you want your
user interface to do, then that
is a quick way to get
started without having to figure
out, I want this panel
to go here, and then having to
style everything and come up
with all the attributes
yourself.
So it can save you
a lot of time.
But if you want to use some of
the more complex widgets that
are not part of UI app, then
basically your only choice is
to write it all
programmatically.
You can mix and match the two.
So you can start with a basic
template that you
build in GUI builder.
And then as you load the
component, then you can add
things to it programmatically if
you want to extend it or do
things that you couldn't do
straight out of the box.
I hope that's helpful.
IKAI LAN: Great.
Eric, give us give a thumbs up
if there's anything that's not
Google Glass related.
We don't have any news
about Google Glass.
I'm sorry.
JAN KLEINERT: I wish We did.
That would be cool if next week
we were sitting here with
what the glasses on.
But I don't think
we're going to.
MALE SPEAKER 3: He actually
posted another question that
said "not one or the other.
The question is how to switch
between the two tools on one
UI, steps to do/" I think it
sounds like he wants to build
some of it in GUI and then
build some of it--
add on to it with script.
JAN KLEINERT: I think we
have an example of
how to do this somewhere.
What I'll do is I'll try to dig
that up and post it as a
response to the original
question in the Moderator page
afterwards.
I can't remember off the top my
head whether that is in the
tutorial section or if it's
something that we had in the
old forum or Stack Overflow.
But we do have some examples
of how you
can use the two together.
OK.
IKAI LAN: OK.
We've got someone else
on the live Hangout.
I'm sorry we haven't given
you a chance to speak.
Is there something you wanted
to ask us are talking about?
JAN KLEINERT: Maybe just--
IKAI LAN: Maybe just like--
JAN KLEINERT: Maybe just
there to listen.
That's cool.
IKAI LAN: That's cool, too.
JAN KLEINERT: All right.
Well, I think that's actually
all for me.
Did you have anything else you
wanted to talk about today?
IKAI LAN: We can go
back to bantering.
JAN KLEINERT: Or we could not.
JAN KLEINERT: Jan and Eric
recently just moved.
So they used to sit a little
bit further from me.
And they moved to right
next to me.
So now we are just literally
within earshot all day long.
So I think that they've
had enough of me.
JAN KLEINERT: That's not true.
That's not true.
But I think we're--
unless we have anymore live
questions, I think we might be
just about out of
stuff for today.
IKAI LAN: OK.
Great.
Well, thank you all for
joining us today.
JAN KLEINERT: All right.
And we'll see you next week.
IKAI LAN: And again, Eric
is in the background.
He's running things.
So a special thanks to
Eric for powering us.
All right.
JAN KLEINERT: All right.
See you next week.